Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Virtual Reality, VR in short, is maturing
at a rapid pace and its promise is truly incredible.
If one day it comes to fruition, doctors could
be trained to perform surgery in a virtual
environment, we could train pilots with better
flight simulators, teach astronauts to deal
with zero-gravity simulations, you name it.
And you will see that with today’s paper,
we are able to visit nearly any place from
afar.
Now, to be able to do anything in a virtual
world, we have to put on a head-mounted display
that can tell the orientation of our head,
and often, hands at all times.
So, what can we do with this?
Oh boy, a great deal.
For instance, we can type on a virtual keyboard,
or implement all kinds of virtual user interfaces
that we can interact with.
We can also organize imaginary boxes, and
of course, we can’t leave out the Two Minute
Papers favorite, going into a physics simulation
and playing with it with our own hands.
In this previous work, hand-hand interactions
did not work too well, which was addressed
one more paper down the line, which absolutely
nailed the solution.
This followup work would look at our hands
in challenging hand-hand interactions, and
could deal with deformations, lots of self-contact
and self-occlusion.
Take a look at this footage.
And, look, interestingly, they also recorded
the real hand model with gloves on.
We might think, what a curious design decision!
What could that be for?
Well, what you see here is not a pair of gloves,
what you see here is the reconstruction of
the hand model by this followup paper.
Absolute witchcraft.
Now, as you see, we can manipulate objects,
or even wash our hands in virtual reality.
This is all great when we play in a computer
game, because the entire world around us was
previously modeled, so we can look and go
anywhere, anytime.
But what about operating in the real world?
What if we wish to look at a historic landmark
from afar?
Well, in this case, someone needs to capture
a 360-degree photo of it.
A regular photo will not cut it, because we
can’t turn our head around and look behind
things.
And this, is what today’s paper will be
about.
This new paper is called Omniphotos, and it
helps us produce this 360 view synthesis,
and when we put on that head-mounted display,
we can really get a good feel of a remote
place, a group photo, or an important family
festivity.
So, clearly, the value proposition is excellent,
but we have two questions.
One, what do we have to do for it?
Flailing.
Yes.
We need to be flailing.
You see, we need to attach a consumer 360-camera
to a selfie stick, and start flailing for
about 10 seconds.
Like this.
This is a crazy idea, because now, we created
a ton of raw data, roughly what you see here.
So this, is a deluge of information, and the
algorithm needs to crystallize all this mess
into a proper 360 photograph.
What is even more difficult here is that this
flailing will almost never create a perfect
circle trajectory, so the algorithm first
has to estimate the exact camera positions
and view directions.
And hold on to your papers, because the entirety
of this work is handcrafted, no machine learning
is in sight, and the result is quite general
technique,
or in other words, it works on a wide variety
of real-world scenes, you see a good selection
of those here.
Excellent.
Our second question is, this is, of course,
not the first method published in this area,
so how does it relate to previous techniques?
Is it really better?
Well, let’s see for ourselves!
Previous methods either suffered from not
allowing too much motion, or, the ones that
give us more freedom to move around, did it
by introducing quite a bit of warping into
the outputs.
And now, let’s see if the new method improves
upon that.
Oh yeah, a great deal!
Look, we have the advantages of both methods,
we can move around freely, and additionally
there is much less warping than here.
Now, of course, not even this new technique
is perfect, if you look behind the building,
you see that the warping hasn’t been completely
eliminated, but it is a big step ahead of
the previous paper.
While we look at some more side by side comparisons.
One more bonus question: what about memory
consumption?
Well, it eats over a gigabyte of memory.
That is typically not too much of a problem
for desktop computers, but we might need a
little optimization if we wish to do these
computations on a mobile device.
And now comes the best part.
You can browse these Omniphotos online through
the link in the video description, and even
the source code, and a Windows-based demo
is available that works with and without a
VR headset.
Try it out and let me know in the comments
how it went!
So, with that, we can create these beautiful
Omniphotos cheaply and efficiently, and navigate
the real world as if it were a computer game.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!